[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the
michigan head coach coach howard joining
us on the program
as they hook up with the winner of mount
saint mary's
and texas southern that'll be saturday
at three eastern
coach i know you're from chicago do you
care about the chicago bears
quarterbacking situation now that andy
dalton is there and you missed out on
russell wilson
hey what's up dan uh first of all i want
to say thank you for uh
for inviting me on your show uh to
answer your question
yes i do care about the chicago bears
and what's happening with our
quarterback situation
i'm the biggest bears fan there is uh
and i'm following it closely
uh no offense to the quarterbacks are
there
under contract but the russell wilson
situation sounds very very interesting
now you got andy dalton instead of
russell wilson when are you guys going
to get a quarter do you think you get a
good quarterback in your lifetime
jumon well we have a good quarterback
you know mitch is a
a good quarterback um andy dalton's a
good quarterback
nick falls a good quarterback nick foles
is a super bowl quarterback
i'm talking about a great on the hall of
fame quarterback
hall of fame quarterback uh you know
that's still
to be you know determined
uh russell like i said it sounds
interesting he's
truly looking at a hall of fame
you know canton ohio appearance
do you practice at all with your team no
no no i don't practice i don't play
basketball man i i let that go
when's the last time you played when's
last time you played
i would say maybe four years ago when i
was an assistant with the miami heat
and it was a summer time asan whiteside
was the only big and we didn't have
anyone to guard him
and we only had eight guys well seven
guys so
just all hands on deck to whoever can to
help
hassan get a good workout i played four
and four with the guys and i guarded
hassan whiteside
now no offense to their son and he may
tell you a different story
but our team won and i had a huge impact
on the game
huge
do you remember your stats from that
game you probably do don't you yeah
you know you always remember your last
game stats
do you remember your welcome to the nba
moment
yes i do i remember my first shot was a
it got blocked by dino roger
i was going through a back down crab
dribble and i'm getting ready going to
my move and
you know dino rogers just sat on it and
i turned
to my shoulder fake and um i tried to
raise and shoot it and he blocked the
shot
i was like wow welcome to the nba young
fella
yeah but dino couldn't jump though juwan
and jawah can jump either
i make two of us what do you what do
your kids say when they see you play
any of the highlights well they they do
say like
okay dad well you you was a bucket
getter um
okay you had a little talent you had
some skill
um you know they they didn't get a
chance to really watch me play until the
end of my career
so they do not quite know um the impact
that i had on the nba or in college
and you know luckily that there are some
folks out there that are still saving
some video
where they're able to see it because
back then we have vcrs
but but the fab five gives you
immortality juwan
it helps it helps the fat five
documentary helped a little bit too he
gave me a little uh street cred
how how close was the fab five to not
happening
very close um because you were kind of
recruiting everybody weren't you
correct you know if you go back to my
my senior in high school and
no actually go back further than that my
junior year in high school and
illinois was the front runner you know
and the university of illinois
at that time was coach lou olsen and i
used to always every summer
uh go to teen camp at the university of
illinois and
jimmy collins was the lead recruiter so
illinois
got into a situation with the bruce
pearl who was an assistant with iowa
yeah and there was a tape conversation
with dion thomas a recruit
out of chicago illinois area and uh that
situation sort of put a little damper on
the plans for me to attend illinois
because
my senior year i was waiting to see what
happened with the ncaa
and illinois if they were going to get
any type of violations or whatever and
in november was the time that i was
going to commit and
michigan moved into being a front runner
and then when i recruited to you
well when i committed to the university
of michigan i started to recruit other
players like jimmy king and
i also started to recruit chris webber
extremely hard and
i can't take credit for ray jackson he
was already committed to the university
of michigan
but um i can truly take credit for jimmy
and chris and chris uh did a lot of
recruiting with jalen
and then well chris was looking at duke
wasn't he
chris chris looking at duke and michigan
state
oh well you know izzo said that that's
the recruit that made him cry
like he lost weber and he said that
that's the one that hurt him
yeah yeah well now you know as a coach
where you're recruiting and somebody can
break your heart yeah but i haven't
cried
it's yet early though it's it's like i
said yeah yeah the key word i said yes
if i told you three years ago your team
would be a number one seed
you'd be coaching michigan be a number
one seed what would you say
well i would say dan now we got a lot of
work to do um
you know we you gotta take one game at a
time um
but you had a hard time you you wanted a
coach in the nba you and
you and patrick ewing you were kind of
hoping to get a head coaching job
and then that was the goal as i was as
an assistant with the heat
the goal was uh developing and which
eric spoelstra did and you know
pat riley david fizdale keith
smart dan craig chris quinn
all those guys i was learning from and
they were helping me to develop
to become a head coach someday and give
a lot of credit to spo
uh he was really was grooming me to
someday be a head coach in nba
and that time uh
each it was like the last two years
before
i took the michigan job you know i went
on recruiting
night recruiting i'm sorry um interviews
to interview for head jobs with the nba
team
but i was always asked a question from
family and friends if i ever wanted to
coach
college would i and my answer was always
michigan
if that job ever became available that's
the only school i would coach
um now you know it's a dream job my
dream came true
still have a goal to coach in the nba i
never even thought about that that's the
past now
really i'm so locked in to michigan good
uh i love this place um i'm enjoying my
experience i'm
growing each and every day growing with
my staff to become
a better coach i tune in to the game
against maryland and that's when the
bench is cleared i had no idea what
happened there
didn't know until a few minutes after
there
have have you watched that video of what
happened
oh yeah i watched the video because i
actually wanted to watch it
right after uh i addressed the team
apologized to the team and i wanted to
go back and
and see like how it all happened and i
knew how it happened but
it's like an out-of-body experience yeah
i mean i was
totally stunned and i was also
disappointed in how i reacted
because as the leader of this team and i
felt that
i should have did a better job of
controlling my emotions
well as you said look it's take your
notes it's in the past i don't want to
talk about this anymore with
you know your conversation with coach
turgeon but
you know your team rallies around you
too
which is the most important part because
they pick you up
uh and you know same thing with patrick
ewing i mean
his team picked him up you know they
went four in a row in the in the big
east
have you talked to ewing uh this year
i reached out to him right away when i i
saw that they won the big east
championship which is very hard to do in
a tough conference and
um you know there are a lot of you know
i would say these uh these experts you
know picking your
team to really fall out or not even make
it that far
and uh coach coach stepped up and his
team like you said they rallied behind
him
um he prepared them and they went out
and competed
and they competed every game and i'm so
happy for him so i hit him up right away
and
uh he he hit me right back because you
know i don't know if you notice or not
dan
i played for pat he was an assistant
coach
with the houston rockets when jeff van
gundy was our head coach
and we had a staff of thibodeau
also uh steve clifford and pat
which was a hell of a staff all head
coaches and jeff van gundy was the head
coach
and pat and i have a great relationship
what if i said that coaches
have to play in the ncaa tournament so
you got to
you got to eat every team's coach has to
play like five minutes like how how
would michigan do against some of the
other teams that you might be facing
well i know we on radio
and i have to be very careful with my
words but this is the competitor
um speaking here uh i always put it like
this
we're not losing we're not losing that's
and i have a lot of trust
and belief in myself and and i still
train i still work out but it's never
basketball shape but
we're for competitors only anytime
there's any coach that want to lace it
up and play one-on-one
and i know stackhouse i know he's
listening you know he's probably the
only one that
i think that will give me a little bit
of competition because i know he's in
great shape he plays pretty much every
day
you're not worried about bryce drew stop
stop
what about ewing too slow
oh my god that's my guy man that's good
do your players ask you about your uh
michael jordan
moment do they have have they asked you
about that and and what is your michael
jordan moment
yeah i've gotten a question uh just
about
a month ago after practice uh terence
williams jr
asked me a michael jordan question about
the time planning the dome
uh when jordan was filming the movie
space jam and
they saw some footage where i was
playing and we were playing shirts and
skins
and they actually you know about you
know my relationship with michael and
um and i talked about the brotherhood
that we both share and
how much i've learned from him uh and
his work ethic and watching
while michael was shooting a movie he
still was training for nba season
talked about how we played that night
every night five days a week
pick up versus some high level talents
and nba ball players
all stars hall of famers you name it um
that's all i gave them you know all the
other stuff man i can't give them man
you know i [ __ ] chicago you know there's
this
famous word that they say snitches get
stitches
[Laughter]
but everybody has that moment where you
go oh man i'm guarding jordan or
jordan you know he's going to say
something like everybody had a larry
bird moment
that you know bird would say something
to to people but
did you have that moment with jordan
where
you probably were in the wrong place at
the wrong time well i recall the time
when mj was the president
of the washington wizards and i i was
a player on the washington wizards and
he practiced one day with us
he's done it before more than once but
the first practice uh
i didn't know he's really practicing you
know he got out there and
he still had an impact on the game uh
very effective out there and
he was talking some trash uh doing the
typical michael thing and
uh he reminded us that he had beat us in
a
in a playoffs and swept us i thought
that was uh well you know he
he had below the belt michael knows how
to hit below the belt you know how to
push the right buttons
wait was that the bradford smith game no
no no no okay no that was later
that was the first round when it was uh
the boys championship team they
they won it that year and on my team it
was
myself weber george mirason
raj strickland and cal bertini
respectable five yeah yeah we were a
young group
we were very young uh c webb tells great
stories about jordan
he said that they showed up at the
chicago stadium and mike's
you guys got off the bus
like i said man snitches get stitches
man
some stories you just can't tell man you
gotta let it go
come on come on i'm not telling that
story nope nope nope
mike's smoking a cigar sitting on a
lamborghini and then he's like
you know who's got a guard who's going
to guard me tonight
with some language attached to that
right hey i'll let webb tell you that
[Laughter]
hey congrats on the season so far a lot
of fun and i know you're not fully
assembled there with your lineup but uh
good luck in the tournament hey dan i
appreciate it man
um i see that cool shirt you have so
when you have time
you just send me one of those t-shirts
i'd be saying paddy's day
that's happy dan patrick's day
that's dope yeah i'll send one out to
you
no doubt double x double x happy uh dan
patrick's day
uh good luck in the tournament thank you
juan great to talk to you thank you
always man stay safe all right juan
howard